ouais tu peux si tu zoomes
autant que tu peux ouais Betty à l'autre
bout et il a l'air un peu la fête que dans
l'autre sens ouais c'était mieux que dans
l'autre sens nah wow ce genre de comme
nous laissez-nous savoir  ok va faire le livret prends
ce côté a plus de lumière oh il y a cette
publicité
ouais c'est cool
c'est un joli coup et j'étais un buisson
on peut monter un peu plus dans la rue mais
les gens qui cherchaient les trottoirs le
préparent des billets de spectacle à prix réduit
voici votre  les gens sur le trottoir ouais
ça a l'air vraiment
on va le refaire rire mais
c'en est un et puis on va en faire
un de plus ça a l'air très bien
faisons entre les bâtiments
eh bien c'est tellement génial
ils m'appellent m'ont
mangé le [ __ ] d'accord  bien finir d'accord nous
bien merci beaucoup non plus le temps que
nous allons chercher de l'aide pour explorer l'horrible blanc
altima 3206 l'approbation de Ralph 1500
trafic est à votre 11 une poche suis-je
presque toutes les clés en elle pour taper Peppa
non nous allons essayer s'il vous plaît  être un look
comme une Porsche pour danser le tango  Delta mais n'entendez pas
ce qui se passe si nous pouvons l'amener directeur à
GW et sur le tee d'aller au
réservoir d'Oradell, je dois le faire George
et ensuite vers l'ouest signifie en fait que
nous pouvons aller mal ouais je pense aussi bien l'
utiliser correctement  qu'est-ce que tu vas faire d'autre
avec ça comme ça ouais je le ramasse je
ne sais pas si tu es un à
deux heures demain ouais je retire
son petit peu d'XP quand tu peux
piéger le vent  pousser et je vais rompre d'
où venez-vous un peu donner l'
impression qu'elle a travaillé plus tard revenir
au bureau des fous comment faire
comme si vous travailliez vous avez
définitivement un peu autre avec un Q une idée
c'est que j'ai oublié ce qu'ils ont sur 95 quoi d'
accord merci les
gens souvent pour l'enseignement supérieur
oh mon Dieu aujourd'hui adulte être revenu aux choses
jusqu'à ce Natalie 40 sur le point de sonner plus
comme le record de autant que j'ai
la capacité de la chose ne le fait pas alors  vous pouvez
fumer ici pour notre pouvoir de déterminer
je pense que
tout le monde est de bonne humeur aujourd'hui c'était
fait bonjour  c'est West être de bonne humeur
quand tu travailles dans la santé mentale d'Emma,
t quand tu es à l'aise avec ça,
u es d'accord, ils sont toujours un peu dans le bain